Predicting how France will line up at the euros
in 60 seconds.
In goal will be Milan keeper Mike Minion.
But remember
this was the World Cup winning team from five years ago
and almost half the players will be replaced.
That's because younger players like William Saliba
have established themselves at the highest level.
I think he'll be paired with Veron's experience,
but they also have Kunde,
Oba Makano, Tobido,
Lucas Hernandez and Konate.
The left back could very well be Lucas Hernandez,
but the other side is harder to predict.
I expect two or many to be the deepest line
midfielder partnered by ravio,
but 0 Emory and Camavingo
will have something to say about that.
Ahead of them will be Griezmann
as we've seen in the past with Didier Deschamp now,
while Mbappe will play on the left.
The right side is dependent on form
coming into the tournament.
You have Dembele,
Kingsley, Coleman,
Colomwani or even Griezmann could shift out wide
and another midfielder filter in.
The striker position is interesting
with Marcus Toronto thriving in Italy,
but I expect France's all time leading goal
scorer to start.
As for the right back,
it's really up in the air.
Kunde and Pavard have the experience,
but my preferred choice would be gusto.
What would be your team?